fertility declines again are one of
these things where well a year ago or so
there were tons of news reports because
there was a Census Bureau that women
were having fewer babies like Millennial
women were having fewer babies than ever
oh what a freak out but it's like
actually what that reflects is the fact
that women have more opportunities and
options and that both men and women want
smaller families because they they're
doing more they're lit we're living
longer we're doing more things it's
actually the decline in fertility is the
result I would argue of modernity
winning of giving people more options
and more control over their biology I
don't see that in and of itself as a
problem that needs to be corrected
because it's also a global phenomenon
everywhere people are having fewer kids
and the reason for that is because they
have more individual control over their
reproduction